what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we actually have quite a bit of
news of things happening in the mcu
we're talking adam warlock and guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 a shang chi spin-off
and ant-man 3 ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania so like i said a lot
happening and not to mention the
director of marvel's what if brian
andrews was asked if we are going to see
more spider-man episodes in what if
season two and the answer that he gave
was kind of interesting and i'll briefly
touch on that but we got a lot to talk
about today and if you love marvel and
love to stay up to date on the mcu be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so this is
all pretty exciting news but let's go
ahead and start with guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and adam warlock now if you
have not seen the post-credits scene for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 i suggest
you go watch that immediately now the
film's been out for a few years so i
don't care about spoilers but you need
to watch it because it sets up adam
warlock specifically it sets up adam
warlock as a product of the sovereign
they literally make him in a cocoon
which is kind of like the comics the
cocoon part that is we can see it on the
front page of one of the fantastic four
issues where adam warlock was actually
called him and the cover reads at last
you will learn what lives within the
cocoon featuring the power of him but in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 they set
him up to appear in volume 3. now since
then a lot has happened with guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 james gunn was fired
and then he was rehired during that time
in between he was hired by warner
brothers to do the suicide squad so
committed to doing that first before he
did guardians vol 3 but guardians 3 of
course is still on and so far he has
hinted at adam warlock still being in
the film and side note he's also hinted
at a lot of potential deaths karen
gillen literally said that she literally
cried while reading the script so who
knows what's gonna happen we have the
hints at deaths and then we have cast
members crying so i'm assuming some
people are going to die and could it be
at the hands of adam warlock now in the
comics adam is indeed a good guy for the
most part he obviously has different
stories but in the comics he does end up
good he helps fight against thanos and
in the mcu we could probably assume that
if he starts off bad he will eventually
turn good fingers crossed because he's
actually one of my favorite characters
and it looks like we could have some
potential casting news on who is going
to be playing adam warlock in the mcu
according to some recent reports that i
will indeed go over will poulter has
been cast as adam warlock and he's been
cast as adam for years now now some of
you and most of you have probably at
least seen will poulter he's from the
chronicles of narnia the maze runner
we're the millers midsummer the revenant
with leonardo dicaprio he's been in some
pretty big movies but what's interesting
i think about this casting choice is
that he's actually a pretty young guy
adam warlock is typically an older guy
adam warlike actually gets with gamora
in the comics and i don't know what the
deal with star-lord and gamora is now
now that we don't really have the real
gamora around but it is kind of hard to
picture a young guy like will poulter
getting with gamora in the mcu now the
fact that some of these reports which
again i'll go over state that he's been
cast for years now makes sense
considering the fact that guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 was supposed to come
out a lot sooner than it actually is
unfortunately because james gunn was
fired and then rehired and committed to
the suicide squad and then cove had
happened we're getting guardians 3 years
after we were supposed to but perhaps
knowing that adam warlock was indeed
going to be coming they did actually
cast him years ago this is something
that i actually think james gunn might
address on twitter he usually does
address things concerning rumors about
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and he
usually says if they're wrong now he
doesn't always do this so don't expect
it but it would be cool if he could
confirm or deny this and which if it is
true i doubt he would confirm it but who
knows today's report about this is
coming from thecosmiccircus.com
now they state that originally there was
a twitter post by at collectaholic
underscore that stated will poulter had
been cast as adam warlock for years now
then they stated that after they saw
this they checked with some of their own
sources several of them and all of them
seemed to say that yes this is a rumor
going around behind the scenes right now
so this is not confirmed to be true but
according to their sources this is
something that is being talked about
behind the scenes which means that it
very well could be true and i'm curious
to see what everybody thinks about this
casting choice in the comments down
below i know a lot of people were
thinking that they would cast somebody
like zac efron which i totally could
have gotten behind but let me know what
you think about this down below and
let's talk about now the shang chi
spin-off series that is coming to disney
plus according to daniel richmond daniel
rpk as he is sometimes known as shared
on his patreon account that there is
going to be a disney plus show that's a
spin-off of shanxi that is going to
focus on the 10 rings organization and
xiling now if you've seen the post
credits scene for shengqi and the legend
of the ten rings this makes perfect
sense in fact when i saw the post credit
for the first time i thought that's
going to be a disney plus show because
it's going to give it enough time enough
episodes to really dive into the
backstory of what is going on here
xiling is now going to be leading the
ten rings organization an organization
that her father never let her be a part
of when she was a kid but now it's all
her she can do whatever she wants but
now the question is and i think a lot of
people have this question walking out of
the theaters is is she going to do good
or is she going to do bad or could it be
a little bit of both could it be one of
those things where it's like well we
kind of gotta do some bad in order to do
some good we're gonna kill people and
topple governments but they're not
exactly the best people or the best
governments i kind of think it's going
to be one of those things especially if
you consider how shang chin the legend
of the ten rings ended the relationship
between her and chongqi yes there's a
big pass there but i don't think she's
going to be like her father i think
she's going to be different but
nevertheless this is a disney plus show
that i can definitely get behind now we
also have ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania news and this is going to be a big
mcu movie i think most people know by
now that king the conqueror is going to
be introduced in ant-man and the wasp
but true king the conqueror yes we did
meet king the conqueror and loki but we
really meant more of a nathaniel
richards not a true king he does say
that people have called him a conqueror
before but the actual person standing in
front of loki and sylvie was not the
same king that we're going to see in
ant-man 3. yes he is going to be played
by jonathan majors but we're probably
going to get the full origin story in
ant-man 3 and he's probably going to be
a lot more savage we met a king that was
kind of done he lived a very very long
time and he was pretty much ready to
retire aka die and this is not going to
be the king at all that we're going to
be meeting in ant-man 3. and here's the
really great news according to
evangeline lilly the script for ant-man
3 is really fantastic she praised the
script saying that i just think that
it's going to be really special i
actually think it has the chance to be
the best one we've done yet and i sure
hope it is the best one and i don't
think that's going to be that hard
considering kang is going to be in it
and we are going to get cassie lang as
stature and considering the fact that
the title is quantum mania i'm assuming
we're going to be getting some pretty
awesome quantum realm scenes so kang is
coming and who knows perhaps they could
introduce the fantastic four in that
movie that's just speculation at this
point not confirmed and the last thing
that we're going to be talking about is
more spider-man in marvel's what if
season 2. now it'll be cool to see
spider-man in what of season 2 but
that's not really what i want to focus
on i really want to talk about how brian
andrews the director of what if acted
when he was asked about spider-man
because i kind of think no way home is
going to affect what happens in season
two because they said season two is
actually going to pull from phase four
stuff that happens in phase four and
when brian andrews was asked by
comicbook.com if we'd see more
spider-man in season 2 he replied with
well we can't talk too much about what
may or may not be happening in season 2
but we do love spider-man so who knows
what may happen in the future i find
this interesting really because of one
reason they've actually talked about
season two before i actually interviewed
brian andrews and the writer of the show
and talked to them about what to expect
in season two and they told me a little
bit of it they told me that peggy
carter's going to come back and gave me
a little bit more detail so they've been
able to talk about season two before but
when it comes to spider-man they can't
really say anything which leads me to
believe that spider-man really is going
to be a multiversal film that affects
the mcu as a whole and who knows if we
do get the three spider-man and
spider-man no way home perhaps we could
get those in what if and hopefully that
is why he cannot talk about it but that
is just my speculation right now let me
know what you think about that and all
of this news in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof